we've learned about series and parallel
resistors we've learned how to simplify
series and parallel resistors into an
equivalent resistor and just to review
for the series resistor our series an
equivalent R series is equal to the sum
of resistors in series r1 plus r2 and we
learned that if we have resistors in
parallel meaning they share the same
nodes if they're in parallel we can get
a parallel to equivalent resistors are
parallel and if there was two resistors
if there's two resistors in parallel the
formula was r1 times r2 over r1 plus r2
plus r2 and if there's three resistors
or more in parallel it's a little more
complicated this formula look like this
1 over R parallel this is for three or
more resistors 1 over r1 plus 1 over r2
plus one over r3 etc for as many
resistors as you have these two parallel
formulas do the same thing this one's a
little more convenient to use when you
just have to when you just have two
resistors so now this problem in this
video we're going to look at a
complicated resistor circuit there's a
lot of resistors here the question we're
going to ask is if we plug in this
voltage source here into our resistor
Network there's the two little plug
points question is what kind of current
is going to be pulled out of this
voltage source that's what I want to
know and if I stare at this I go well
how am I going to figure that out the
important part of what we're doing here
is to stop for a minute and just see
what this circuit looks like it'd just
be with it for a second let your eyes
wander over it and find resistor
patterns that you recognize and you just
wait and do that all right so we're
looking for series and parallel patterns
and there
one and is this this is not in series
nope okay oh there's a possibility
there's a possibility of parallel
resistors this is there a series one
over here I don't see a series
head-to-tail connection here and there's
a series connection here that we can use
okay so there's a couple of
possibilities here for simplification
and one of the questions is okay where
do we start we want to start this
problem at the end farthest away from
the thing we care about what we care
about is this right here this is what
we're looking for and so a good way to
start this problem is to start at the
very far end of the circuit and work our
way backwards and this is opposite the
way you read sentences and things like
that but in circuits it's sometimes what
we want to do so what I'm going to do is
start over here on this side and we're
going to disassemble this circuit and
simplify it as we go so we've actually
at this point we've actually done the
hard work of this and the rest of its
going to be relatively straightforward
application of these two formulas we've
decided what our unknown is when we
decided where to start and that strategy
is the key to this making this a simple
straightforward process all right so
let's go after it we're going to we're
basically now going to do the work of
simplifying this network so what I see
here is two resistors in series two ohms
plus 8 ohms equals 10 ohms so I can
remove these resistors here and replace
them with a 10 ohm resistor that's step
one what do we do next now we look at it
again right here we see we have two
parallel resistors so we're actually
going to use this form we're going to
use this form of the parallel resistor
formula and that says that 10 times 10
over 10 plus 10
is equal to 100 over 20 or 5 ohms and I
could have done this a little quicker if
I I know that if two resistors in
parallel have the same value 10 and 10 I
know that the parallel combination of
those is exactly half so now we have an
equivalent resistor for those two guys
we can take them out and we replace that
with a 5 ohm resistor you can see where
this is going we just basically are
going to collapse this circuit one step
at a time 5 ohms plus one ohm is this
series combination here and that is
equal to 6 ohms so I can replace this
now with 6 ohms we're just consuming our
circuit and erasing and rewriting as we
go
and I said six ohms here and what do we
have now now this is a little more
challenging I have three resistors in
parallel and I'm going to use now this
formula here for resistors in parallel
so one over the parallel combination is
one over twelve plus one over four plus
one over six and the common denominator
is 12 so that is something over 12 which
will be one plus three over twelve plus
two over twelve and that equals six over
12 which is one-half and one over RP
that's one over RP so RP equals two over
1 or 2 ohms and now I can replace all
three of these I get to erase all three
we're almost done
and that was I said 2 ohms 2 ohms final
step is 1 2 ohms in series 1 plus 2
equals 3 and finally we get to the last
step which is
all right so we're done what that means
is from the viewpoint from the as far as
that voltage source can tell it's
putting out enough current to drive
three ohms and that whole rest of that
complicated network looks like three
ohms to that resistor to that voltage
source and we have taken a complicated
circuit and turn it into a really simple
one so that's the steps of
simplification the key was figuring out
what you want and then going to the far
end of the circuit and working your way
backwards and simplifying as you go